madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre et oui jamais la natalité
française n'a été aussi basse depuis
3000 c'est le nombre de naissances en
France en 2022 mais c'est surtout le
chiffre le plus bas depuis 75 ans le pic
de 800000 naissances enregistrées entre
2006 et 2012 paraît bien lointain autre
chiffre inquiétant le taux de fécondité
qui mesure le nombre d'enfants en moyen
par femme est tombé à 1,8 nous sommes
bien loin du taux de 2,1 enfants qui
permet de stabiliser la population il
manque désormais chaque année 40 à 50
000 naissances pour assurer le
renouvellement des générations madame la
première médite nous devons
effectivement nous alerter de ces
chiffres et pourtant ces chiffres ne
sont pas étonnants depuis 10 ans en
effet des choix sont faits pour rompre
délibérément et par idéologie avec la
politique familiale de notre pays qui
faisait pourtant l'objet d'un consensus
politique très large depuis 10 ans sous
le mandat de François Hollande d'abord
sous le mandat d'Emmanuel Macron ensuite
tout objectif de soutien à la natalité
et systématiquement écarté et les
atteintes portées aux allocations
familiales au congé parental et aux
quotient familial pénalistes tout
particulièrement les familles des
classes moyennes et des classes
défavorisées alors madame la Première
ministre allez-vous réagir face à cette
baisse historique de l'indentalité
allez-vous enfin refaire du soutien à la
natalité une véritable priorité
[Musique]